techno festival in einem weltkulturerbe
wo früher hoch öfen geheizt wurden heißt
heute dj wankelmut die menge an
auf dem festival elektromagnetik vor
kurzem als bestes neues festival europas
ausgezeichnet
mit ein grund dafür der austragungsort
das industriedenkmal völklinger hütte im
saarland ganz viel mit algen
spielstarken
gesagt was mit den menschen zeit alles
verbunden so moderne und alte kultur
strandkorb pilsner alias wankelmut ist
einer der bekanntesten djs auf dem
festival 2012 schaffte er mit dem remix
monday einen nummer eins hit in
deutschland österreich und der schweiz
als rosa ist sehr beeindruckend die
gesamte architektur und industrielle
flair sagt ich war und für eine
techno-party ja nicht so ziemlich
passend von haus aus ist techno
maschinen musikmaschinen musik passt
halt in maschinen halten gearbeitet
haben für leute fragen uns ganz oft ja
warum kommen zu viele elektronische
musik aus deutschland und auch
nordengland war auch so eine wiege auch
belgien und das sind alles industrie
dritten länder wo der der pulsschlag
quasi als das metall der der maschinerie
der fabrik immer anscheinend schon in
den in den köpfen oder in den körpern
der leute drin war in der dna drin ist
an diesen maschinen haben arbeiter fast
100 jahre lang eisen und stahl
hergestellt
1986 wurde die völklinger hütte
stillgelegt 1994 wurde sie unesco
welterbe die anlage ist weltweit das
einzige eisenberg aus der blütezeit der
industrialisierung das vollständig
erhalten ist
meinrad grewenig ist leiter des
industriedenkmals völklinger hütte
er möchte die 600.000 quadratmeter große
anlage aber nicht nur erhalten sondern
auch mit kultur beleben
momentan das tier eine street art
ausstellung mit international berühmten
künstlern zu sehen
wir begreifen uns als völklinger hütte
auch als kind oder abkopplung dieser
popkultur denn die hinwendung zum
abgelegten zu industriellen zur
produktion ist ja ein wesentlicher zug
der pop-art und durch die popkultur ist
eigentlich dieser ort industrielle
arbeit zum ersten mal auch als kulturort
sichtbar geworden
früher waren die arbeitsbedingungen in
äußerst hart in der kokerei wurde kohle
auf temperaturen von bis zu 1200 grad
celsius erhitzt in den 60er jahren waren
in der völklinger hütte bis zu 17.000
arbeiter beschäftigt
der bekannteste industriestandort
deutschland aber war das ruhrgebiet ab
mitte des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
trennten dann stahl und kohleproduzenten
aus aller welt auf den markt die anlagen
wurden nach und nach stillgelegt auch
sie sind längst zu orten der kultur
geworden
am gasometer oberhausen ist momentan
eine installation des berühmten
künstlers christo zu sehen
zum dreizehnten mal fand am wochenende
im ruhrgebiet das kulturfestival
extraschicht stadt mehr als 200.000
menschen besuchten die veranstaltungen
in alten zechen und bergwerken
ich habe selbst noch auf verschiedenen
schachtanlagen kokereien gearbeitet als
junger mann und diese dann heute zum zur
extraschicht besuchen um kultur zu
treffen wie sie schon thalmann argen
vergangen hat darüber muss man einfach
spaß wird das eine schöne idee weil es
eigentlich wenn man kann es abreißen und
was würde shoppingcenter draufstellen
oder kann es bewahren und neu nutzen
ziemlich gut
eine der veranstaltungen des festivals
in der henrichshütte in hattingen
schauspieler inszenieren mit werkzeugen
von damals eine geräusch performance
ob als inspirationsquelle oder als
kulisse industrieanlagen haben in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten einen wandel
erfahren
man verwendet haben es war heiß da die
haben die schweiz das war dreck und
trotzdem mal es den sound und sound den
sie mit nach hause genommen ins bett
früh aufgewacht
das war das lied
industrieanlagen werden zu kulturstätten
und denkmäler eine globale entwicklung
allein in großbritannien gibt es sechs
anlagen die zum unesco-welterbe gehören
in deutschland sind es insgesamt vier
und manchmal erobert sich die natur
ihren platz zurück so wie hier in der
völklinger hütte im hinteren bereich
buch hatte jahrzehntelang die wildnis
daraus hat eine landschaftsarchitektin
12 gartenräume gestaltet
wir haben hier in diesem bereich den wir
paradies genannt haben einen ganz
besonderen ort diese kokerei des femmes
grunde die hölle und 25 jahre hat sich
die natur nach der stille sitzung diesen
ort zurück geholt
einmal im jahr erobern sich die
techno-fans den ort bis tief in die
nacht feiern 10.000 besucher in der
völklinger hütte immer noch 7000
menschen weniger als sie einst
gearbeitet haben
trotzdem in die industrieruinen ist
neues leben eingezogen